so Donald Trump just announced he's
giving out the most dishonest and
corrupt media awards to its biggest
offenders this is a first but are you
surprised have you noticed the media is
an object of criticism for the president
so what is that cause well the media
seems as robust as ever everyone's
either a Woodward or Bernstein when they
aren't hi similarly homicides homicides
in Chicago have fallen 60 percent in
2017 a welcome reduction from the
bloodshed that again made its mayor a
target of trumps ire so do you see my
point why didn't this reduction occur
under Obama and why was it the media
more aggressive during the same time the
aggressive journalism and aggressive
policing policing are actually resets
due in part to what I call the PTW
effect prove Trump wrong effect for
years Fox News railed against media bias
that the media care not really for the
last few years we've covered Chicago's
problems did Rahm Emanuel listen at all
no he slammed chick-fil-a instead yeah
now we're seeing the media adjust its
behavior over accusations of fake news
and now a city mayor under a president
who isn't his best friend put more cops
on the street my theory bureaucrats and
media hate Trump so much that they can't
let him win the argument so they up
their game just to shut the guy up so
laugh at Trump's tweets about Chicago or
Iran the media or whatever he chooses to
target it may be the best motivational
tool we got Geraldo you see do you don't
you think the media is now extra
motivated because every time they screw
up they got it they got to listen to
Trump make fun of him well I think that
there I'm old enough to have lived
through and been in the business during
President Nixon and I you know he could
not buy a break president Trump I think
it's even worse press than President
Nixon did yeah I think that every
absolutely everything he does is
construed in the most evil negative way
possible and and these awards that are
coming out next week next Monday it's a
gimmick it's a you know it's kind of a
stick but on the other hand I was in
Puerto Rico with the president when
Paul Krugman the Nobel winning
economists of the New York Times wrote
the story of how president Trump's
neglected Puerto Rico led to a cholera
epidemic in Puerto Rico
there was no cholera epidemic the Nobel
laureate economist for the whatever he's
gonna call these raspberries yeah he's
not intellectual welfare if they let him
say whatever he wants and he's always
wrong Kimberly do you have any
nominations what do you make of these
awards I think this is gonna be very
funny they're gonna have to put
everybody on CNN like Don Lemon and Jake
Tapper and every day like five second
delay losing it freaking out because
they can try to defend themselves say no
no we're gets these awards we're
actually very fair we're honest what
does President Trump saying so I'm sure
they're actually quite nervous about it
and I like that he's taking you know
he's taking control of the situation
he's behind the wheel saying I'm gonna
tell you what I think about you I'm
gonna say it straight to your face and
that's it I'm gonna tell the whole world
I like the approach he's using it I
think effectively diplomatically the
international stage as relates to
national security whether it's
immigration its taxes its his approach
it worked for him during the campaign so
he's doing it still you don't think it
threatened this is the First Amendment I
think the First Amendment is solid last
time I checked I think it'd be fine you
know what it is you know it is Dana it's
something you would do on a show like
every like we put it like what are your
predictions for 2018 or winners and
losers
this is a guy born in bread watching Fox
News the first thing I thought when I
saw it last night is that the five is
one of the best ratings I'm I think it's
good if it's done with a laugh which I
can't eat right so like if it's a let's
hold you up for ridicule and in the
media I don't think that's necessarily
good Krugman is obviously a good example
and I think if the tone and tenor of it
is right I think it could actually be
kind of a joke and maybe even fun for
you buddy I do think there is something
to be said about how other countries see
it and how other countries use it
against their own people and I think
that's not good really do you really
think that argument and I understand and
you know I read the editorials they'd
always say that but I travel a lot it I
no one ever comes up to me and says see
you have fake news in America you know
hey buddy you want to buy some I
remember your selfie with style bad no
I'd say we're watching the Trump
presidency but as you said we're
watching the Trump show and the shows on
at 5:00 so we're gonna get a great note
I think it was on purpose yes yes like
you said in the monologue the media into
being more fair and balanced either that
or he's just branding them as you know
phony losers yeah but also like rahm
emanuel now he's doing this he didn't do
this under obama what that's so weird to
me it was he's thinking I mean it's just
interesting to me I don't think the
media has enough self-awareness to get
course-correct right because I think
they're so blinded by the Trump hatred
that they don't recognize his comedy
chops yeah if I were the CNN people
getting all these awards I would just
say make fun of his hair
I'd say focus on North Korea I laugh
about it yeah they think this is press
genocide in the First Amendment under
it's way too seriously all right